[Music]
hi i'm ruby rose and this is glamour
unfiltered
for june pride issue
[Music]
what makes me feel proud um i think just
getting up every single day and trying
to see the positive and what we're gonna
produce uh as far as a collective
consciousness in the world and
seeing that we've all lived through
something quite traumatic for the last
year and a half
and so i'm proud every day that the
people make a decision to get up and and
try to do their best because it's been
very very challenging and what does
pride mean to me well pride month
as far as the community what it means to
me is that
you know stonewall was a bit over 50
years ago
and to me it represents the community in
a position where their back was up
against the wall and they had to make a
decision to
fight for the freedom that we have today
and that to make a decision to live in
their truth in a public way
in a time when really living in your
truth privately was kind of the only way
people
could do it and feel safe um so for me
pride is
how far we've worked to get to where we
are how hard we've fought and how far we
have to go and how far we have to keep
going
um to keep that legacy alive of what
people have done to get us to where we
are today
[Music]
i came out when i was 12 years old which
is is quite young
um in a way i only knew that to be my
truth i didn't know
any other way i didn't know how to live
without being sort of open and honest
about it but i think i was also very
young
and maybe if i was a little bit older
and i realized how much people were more
homophobic or had different views about
how people should live and
a lack of education in that area and
might not have come out so young but it
was kind of good because people thought
it was a phase
you know it's sort of like you're 12
it's a phase and it didn't get taken as
seriously and then by the time everyone
realized what that really meant what
being gay
meant what being with women meant they'd
kind of gotten used to the fact that
that was
they were like oh i guess she is gay and
i got bullied for it i got
you know tormented i kind of felt like i
got sort of crucified at school and
um it was it was tough being basically
the only gay person
in that school but at the same time when
i was getting ready to
graduate it's like the l word came out
and queer's fault came out and all these
[ __ ] and then everyone at school was gay
everyone had a girlfriend and a
boyfriend and boy i was like
i just missed the precipice which just
goes to show how important it is to have
uh representation in the media
[Music]
orange is the new black was
one of the most extraordinary um
experiences that i've ever had in my
life
the the cast the crew obviously it being
my breakout role in the united states as
well and
coming off the back of not really having
any success in the states and thinking
i'm probably gonna have to go home
you know my visa would expire into this
world
of of jen houston and you know genji and
and these fantastic stories these
fantastic women
and it blew up it really the show
already blew up i mean the show was as
big as it could be but i mean
the season that i did i didn't really i
couldn't have
possibly foreseen that it would have
been uh so well accepted by everyone and
appreciated and there'd be this sort of
fanfare
but i i was very appreciative and i
still am and i i think it was one of the
greatest shows that has been made
so i feel very honored to have been on
it
i mean i feel like when it comes to
giving advice to
one's younger self it's like i know too
much now i know way too much
i think that my inner child my young
self
did a really good job you know with what
she was given and then
the lack of what she had um and i always
kind of people often
talk to the inner child to feel closer
to themselves and they they give them
advice and vice versa but for me i
usually go to my inner child to get
advice
you only have one life and it's a
magnificent gift that's been given to
you and if you're living it for anybody
else or trying to minimize yourself or
make yourself small
for other people so that they're not
they're not uncomfortable
to make their life easier so that you're
not in the way um
you're not living your life to its
potential to
to what you can be and if you don't live
your life to your truth and if you don't
give everything you have into this small
time that we have on this earth
that will be your biggest regret um you
deserve the love you deserve people to
love you for who you are
you deserve to love other people and be
loved so i just
you know just keep fighting keep doing
it keep believing in yourself and keep
listening to that soul
and what it wants and give it to to
yourself because you deserve it
[Music]
i don't really like the stereotypes
thing because i think that the point is
everyone is unique and everyone is
different so
i don't know if there's a certain group
of people that tend to dress a similar
way or like a similar style to music i
i don't know but i think that if that's
what makes you happy that's what makes
you happy i think
stereotypes in any situation are usually
pretty harmful so i would advise
avoid them if if especially if you're
not part of the community um
i would avoid making sort of assumptions
about
different groups within the community
but uh i i it's not something that
i really spend a lot of time on
[Music]
growing up when i got into modeling i
felt like there was a lot of pressure to
look a certain way and
to kind of fit in into the industry and
look like everybody else and
because i didn't take that route and and
didn't go that way i just kept going
more edgy and kind of trying to carve
out a place
for myself even though that i was told
there wasn't one there and so i i had my
short hair my tattoos the way that i
dressed um
the music that i listened to and and i
found that i had my strengths there but
as i started to get a little bit of
success
then i started to feel more like do i
owe it to
to them whoever them is you know do i
owe it to the people that hired me for
this
to wear this dress do i owe it to this
person to
to present myself in this way because
maybe that's what they want um and so
then it became
grappling constantly and i still do it
all the time you know is this like that
i want to do is this a
general um exploration of myself
you know in growth or is this just me
trying to appease other people
um and i generally can notice it cause i
start to feel a little empty i start to
feel less
inspired and charged and happy and and
then i have to kind of take inventory
and realize what is my authentic self
saying and what have i outgrown and what
is
coming for me
social media is well it's here
you know social media is social media
it's going to exist whether we like it
or not i think there's a
tremendous amount of positives as far as
community and being able to find people
that
you know you relate to and having uh
being able to make friends and having
connection which is obviously the sort
of the main point of it at least
how it started and then as far as the
negative points of social media i think
we don't know the long-term effect
effects of social media so i don't know
what it's going to do to our brains and
what it's going to do
to our attention spans and um even our
self-worth
and our self-worth right i've now got a
lisp
um but i think if we use it correctly
and we take
control of when it doesn't make us feel
good you know if you're scrolling
through
social media and you're not feeling good
you're feeling anxious or
like someone else has got this great
life and you're not doing anything and
you're depressed or
it's making you just want to crawl up
and go back to bed which you can do then
you need to sort of take that
and and twist it around and go okay
that's not working for me what's gonna
make me happy today is
do i need to create something do i need
to draw do i need to go for a walk
be in nature um but do i need to take a
rest from social media and i think when
we take those rests
it's actually a fantastic platform if we
get used by it
instead of using it then it becomes
disadvantage to us
[Music]
when i was reading about the character
and victoria and her daughter
i was really impressed and moved and i
felt this immediate
thought of my mum because she was a
single mum when she had me shed me at 20
and and we
you know we were just vagabonds around
australia living in sort of this
bohemian lifestyle on couches and in
caravans and trailers and different
places this woman victoria would do
anything it takes to to rescue and save
and protect her daughter and i
know that when my mom had me it was
exactly that she would have done
anything to protect me up until
even now even in fact even now my mother
would do anything to protect me
so i really loved that aspect of the
story and i thought it gave victoria a
lot of
um purpose and meaning and it meant that
every situation was really high stakes
and high risk and it was an emotional
um film and i did feel very proud kind
of representing my mum in that
[Music]